No, everybody welcome to another Zoom call, we don't have that many questions today, so if you have anything make sure you chat it in.
So we don't exit before you get your question answered.
Let's jump right to the questions.
This was a long one recently thought I was doing really great.
What a pain started in my spine and radiated all around my rib cage.
Big red flags as this is how I began turns out from an MRI basically my whole spine is littered with lesions now.
Some taking over my entire vertebrae.
Now that it's been two weeks and the shock is ward off I've decided to go back to IVC therapy and ordered 30 milligrams hypermectin to take one a day for 90 days.
Yeah, colleges has not bothered to call me.
I don't know what else to do because I am using the right every night and have been doing so for over a year to half.
Except for some power outages and I eat really clean and follow food supplement protocol.
There has been one of the biggest and greatest things in my life lately and I will always trust God.
The best outcomes.
As is his will you have any suggestions for me I would greatly appreciate them.
Yeah well I'm very sorry to hear this and remember you know if anything does change in anybody's life like this is the first I've heard about this.
Make sure you get a hold of us right away that's what we're here for and I know this you're getting a hold of us.
Maybe you were in shock for two weeks so this is how you're getting a hold of us is just through a question.
The zoom call but we're here to pray for you or here to to seek God's answers and all of this and pray about decisions moving forward so we're here for you.
You know the good times and the bad times so just know that for all of you that I know I don't want to.
I've done it when you're needing us that's what we're here for.
Okay so some some comments that I would have on this 30 milligrams I've erected depending upon your weight is probably not going to be enough I've erected there is a.
Anybody can Google it the chart or looking up I've erected dosage for cancer and it is based upon your weight.
I'm just typing it in right now so I can see if I can find it based upon your weight and it's just type in that I've erected dosage for cancer you'll be able to see that but you do want to get up to the right dosage for.
For your can for your weight.
So I don't think 30 milligrams is enough I've erected to be at the dose that's recommended for cancer.
Number two the intermediate vitamin C therapy I think that's great that's a great oxidative therapy if that's what you feel like God is leading you to there's other things like bend is all that's much less expensive you put dollar signs after this in your question.
There's a bed that is all is is much cheaper than I've erected you can do both of them together if you wanted to and it's certainly a whole lot cheaper than interpretive vitamin C so.
Give us a call the other thing you should look at is getting another cheeks one done at least have a conversation with me.
And there's call marine and and schedule something as soon as you can like to chat with you about that so.
And definitely we're praying for you so you don't have to know who this is to be prayed for someone and all you guys know that you need to be praying for each other and one of the greatest things.
What happened when you go through a difficult time is that you grow in your empathy for others and I know it's easy when we're going through a difficult time that we are become very self focused but our priorities to be that we become very God focused like this person said they're trusting God's will in their life and we become other people focused.
And we pray for other people sometimes that's the greatest thing we can do we say well that's the least I could do is pray for you.
Yes, we're supposed to help out as many things as we can do if we're gifted to do so but that's not a small thing to do when we pray for someone that's a very big thing to do so.
I'd ask that everybody listening to this or who listens to this is future be prayed for each other pray for this person who just found that they have castles this right for other people not only for healing but for God's will to be dealt with their life for a greater deeper stronger relationship with him and dumb.
And that's that's the key so this person I asked that they get a hold of us I will look up who this was and I'll have read reach out to you as well on your supplement recommendation for me as of 9 30 24 could you revise the list in order of importance.
So I put this question in here because this person asked the question obviously I'm not going to share their supplement list with everybody on this thing but I put this question here just to remind me to tell everybody that yes I want to be completely understanding of people's financial situation so from a financial situation.
This person I believe is in a more relative state of remission and they could cut down on their supplements I get that question you know not it's not a common but I get the question that hey can you put my list in an order of importance for financial reasons more so I get the the question can you put my list in order of importance because I hate taking supplements and I'm just not going to take.
I just I just got supplement burn out it's really easy when you have a serious disease you're willing to do a ton of stuff and take everything and you get to a point where you do get supplement burn out that's a real thing I get that and so yes I will hopefully tomorrow look at your list and put it in order and I'll email so.
I'll email you the list of importance 12345 that you can decide what you want to do and what you can do that's okay back to this question to there's a and I will also make a note of things that you can pulse that's how you can save money and you can save on supplement taking burn out my pulsing supplements so you may take one every other day and take a different one the opposite every other day and it means they'll go twice as far.
And you'll take half as many supplements so that's another thing I may recommend to my latest urinalysis lab it showed a clarity as easy and a trace amount of protein in my urinalysis lab.
amorphous crystals which are abnormal my GP call to ask if I have a history of kidney stones which I don't the last time I had an abnormal your religion bill and religion reading but this was normal now I'm wondering if some supplement I'm taking is causing some weird you a results which I've never had before.
I have to look at your supplement unless I if you were taking if unless you change to a different supplement something some new supplement i mean if some if there was a supplement that you were taking that was causing amorphous crystals.
You think they would have been causing amorphous crystals you know the whole time you were taking the supplement and now they just all of a sudden started causing that so I unless it's something new that you're taking I don't think it's that.
When you when you have amorphous crystals in a ua and trace about a protein a ua you're also going to look at are you dehydrated but you have an increased concentration of your urine so these things are showing I don't know what we do some research on that kidney stones can be caused from.
Oxilates so if you happen to be eating a lot of oxilates we used to see this we did more ua's and people in office during times where they're eating a lot of rhubarb and things that have a lot of oxilates in them with different times in the season you see some different changes.
I'd have to look at your genetics I think we did you genetics on this person who asked this question to see if you have any genetic defects on your oxilates genes that.
That that expulsion of those so I would have to I'd have to do some investigation on your genes to to see if that's an issue to.
Yeah, but I will look I'll try to look at your supplement listed and let me know if there's anything you added or changed recently between.
ua analysis is I like to know more about low iron and it's relationship to cancer I've been taking optiferin C every other day for about six or eight weeks it as I was muzzle tested for it I just had a colonoscopy and all was okay there so no bleeding for anything.
I just had labs done again in my ferritin was 54 August it was 16 so let's stop there a second and discuss ferritin so ferritin is the primary storage form of iron in the body it's called iron is stored.
If you have decreased levels of ferritin it's commonly associated with iron deficiency.
But but there's other tests that you have to compare it to if you're going to diagnose iron deficiency not solely just ferritin.
Increased levels can be associated with iron overload but increased levels are really a marker of inflammation.
And so people that have really high ferritin levels it's means they have a lot of inflammation a lot of inflammation and blood increases their risk of cardiovascular disease.
They have a lot of oxidative stress point again low levels can be iron deficiency anemia can actually be vitamin C insufficiency let's say if a person was fasting for a long period of time.
And I think you mentioned here about your thyroid can also be tied to hypo thyroid issues.
So ferritin was 16 August and you got up to 54 after taking iron supplementation which would suggest that if there's a correlation there that supplementation of iron increase ferritin which would suggest that it was really the low ferritin was from iron deficiency anemia.
But iron went from 59 to 42 so a little discussion on iron so serum levels of iron reflect what is bound to serum proteins.
So you have different proteins in your blood transfer it is a protein in your blood that folds iron serum iron levels will fall when you have depletion of iron stores you have if you start to develop anemia iron deficiency anemia that we're talking about.
So when a person has low iron that you're starting to think about iron deficiency anemia but also you could have also the other thing you should look at what you have low iron you have low red blood cells and you have other signs of anemia like a decreased mch a decreased mcv a decrease mchc.
hc typically a decreased ferritin that I already discussed decreased percent transfer and saturates decrease hemoglobin decreased hematocrit at an increased red cell with the R&W then for sure you have iron deficiency anemia so there's different types of anemia that can tie to this.
But the other thing you want to look at is am I losing iron somehow by bleeding so it's not uncommon if you're if you're still having your period that you could be losing iron through your period you already made mention that you did a colonoscopy and there wasn't any bleeding involved well colonoscopy only goes up through your colon.
you have you know 25 feet of small intestine and you have your stomach also that you could be losing blood at two so you want to look at am I losing blood somewhere typically if you have a bleeding ulcer if it's if it's bad enough you'll have a darker stool even a black tary stool if you have a really bad bleeding ulcer typically also have pain from it but you can have just a mild bleeding ulcer and you're losing blood that way too.
The other thing you're concerned with with cancer and iron is that cancer if cancer is growing in a person anemia is common because cancer tends to gobble up iron so that's the relationship that cancer has with iron.
So if your red blood cell count is steady at four still with the normal range your said my iron went from 59 to 42 so that went down with total iron by the capacity stayed at 370 and technically 370 is too high so total iron by the capacity is.
The approximation of the serum transfer level so remember I said serum transfer was a protein in the serum that binds iron.
It carries iron around in the blood so elevated levels of.
Total iron by the capacity are associated with iron deficiency anemia and the I think the the lab levels the ranges the optimal range of total iron by the capacity I think of both labs is about 250 to.
430 or something like that but the really the functional range is like 250 to 350 so you would be elevated above the functional range there which ties into the low iron which ties into iron deficiency so I would number one you're trying to investigate why do I have iron deficiency can it be because of low thyroid possibly can it be because of.
possible bleed somewhere still possibly you can do a simple occult blood test where you put a little sphere of feces on a little.
This little card thing you can buy these occult blood tests different place after look up we have a use those for years but you can test that I will test for what's called occult blood which means like hidden blood in your feces which will.
It which is kind of an investigation of am I losing blood through my digestive track somewhere so you could have a hidden slow bleed stomach ulcer or do wandal ulcer that it's not causing you know it's not causing enough blood loss that's causing black tary stools but you still could have enough blood loss to have a slight anemia because you would be in that category of a slight anemia you don't have all these other.
factors that I mentioned of anemia but you do have low iron and elevated above functional range of total iron binding capacity so.
By definition you're you're at the early stages of anemia or coming out of anemia so hopefully it's getting better so we want the total iron binding capacity to be to drop down and we want your iron levels to go up and your fairytale levels could stay pretty much where they're at right there and we want that to go on.
I'm reading continuing your question reading on the internet I saw that low thyroid could be responsible for low iron by TSH improved from seven to 2.3 because I've been taking the glandular that you suggested.
I don't know if I should be concerned that my low iron is some kind of cancer indicator I've tend to run a little low in my life but not usually out of range so.
Can have a kid let's say I could be feeling great I have no other sides of cancer coming back but I look at my CBC and complete metabolic panel and I've seen early stages of anemia is that a side of the cancer coming back that's your question some kind of cancer indicator you want to compare that with past.
Test so past tests past CBC's have shown even a worsened levels of anemia and this is still showing slight anemia but it's not it's not gone you know it's not gotten a lot worse and I would say no it's not an indicator of cancer growing but I would say something you do want to keep an eye on this is why you know doing these
deep dives into simple blood tests like a CBC can give you a lot of a lot of clues that something is going on.
It's it's that's important to do I just spoke to somebody the other day who had a blood test done you know several months ago it showed some clues of metastasis that their oncologist never even never even actually went over the blood test.
So it's it's you miss the clues if you don't dig into it so digging into this is basically my first clue would be iron deficiency anemia possible internal bleeding that would be causing iron deficiency anemia and then the other thing that I did it.
Really talk about is the other possibility of hypochloridria so hypochloridria you mentioned hypochlorid which can tie to it but what mainly hypochlorid ties to ferritin not so much iron but the other thing that could cause low iron and elevated total iron binding capacity is another thing which is hypochlorid.
So what do you have a decrease hydrochloric acid in your stomach that can also tie that can also be a cause of low serum iron so you need adequate levels of stomach acid to absorb iron so a person can be deficient in iron so they basically have a deficiency in iron in order for iron to be used.
By hypochlorid but it can be brought to the cells because they have a decrease hydrochloric acid in their stomach they're not able to absorb it.
Now typically you want to look at the complete metabolic panel and look at total globulin because many times you'll have an increased total globulin with hypochloridria as well.
If you also have an increase in your blood urea nitrogen then it's that you probably for sure have hypochloridria now that's probably the easiest fix of all because that's taking HCl or apple cider vinegar with your food and taking more with larger meals.
So and I will say that every dysfunction of the human body in all of mankind throughout the entire world hypochloridria is probably the most common thing that exists that's done to them.
Especially in a world that is eat a western diet because everything that we eat food, attitudes, colorate, preservatives, chemicals, everything we eat affects our stomach, vital cells ability to make hydrochloric acid.
So hopefully that helps.
What are the best right programs for this cold and flu season and of course the 2024 COVID possibilities?
Well, there's COVID programs on the right, there's cold and flu programs on the right, the cold and flu oncoming is probably my favorite.
So the the modium blaster if you feel like you got something in your chest is my favorite the modium program, but remember these are all frequency so you should just run them when you shouldn't just be trying different ones and running those different programs to try to keep yourself as healthy as possible.
I tried to search, I've erected dosage cancer and the results aren't easily found, there are maybe studies to comb through, but if you have a trusted source for this, let me look, see where it was.
I thought I put it on the member site, the so the treatment dose for a female at 150 pounds, let's say you have breast cancer.
And you can't seriously test this.
But, but I think it's a remember I think for I think it was a 60 milligrams for a 50 150 pound person, I think that was that was about the average.
Yeah, this is not working to take it I'm trying to work out there so I'll have to dig that out.
I'll put it up on the member site.
But I am probably has died when I started using a new one, it has a pink light, all my others had a blue light and the water does not get near as dirty as previous.
There was a loose washer and not in the unit, do you think it's working properly or could something be wrong?
Yeah, I don't know, I mean most of them come with an extra plastic washer and not so if that's what you're talking about the loose nut or was it loose inside the unit, it shakes and it's loose.
They're pretty easy to take apart and look and fix.
But yeah, I'm sure I'm doing that it's loose inside the unit.
You can obviously unplug it and you can unscrew that and take it apart and look at it and see if there's something loose inside make sure everything's connected.
Most of them come with an extra plastic washer.
And I don't know if you got it from us or from true right and you could call true right and ask them they would be the best people to talk to them about that.
My right system with right sheet shocks me with amplification.
Anyone else having this issue?
Remove the amplification no shock.
But this should not do this.
What's the purpose of amplification if it shocks you?
Right never has the answers.
I don't know if you're talking about true right never has the answers to that.
But as far as the right giving you shocks with the with the jackhammer amplification piece on it that is very common.
So the really again take a step back.
I only recommend using the jackhammer.
If you're going to use the bulb.
If you for overnight use putting it far away from you or putting it under your band so we have some people.
Because I remember I always recommended that you use the bulb.
This is prior to ever having the jackhammer amplification this for people that are listening to this were talking about the true right system.
So the if you have the jackhammer amplification.
We've always only recommended using that if you're not going to have the bulb right next to you.
If you're going to have the bulb right next to you don't use the jackhammer amplification.
The whole purpose of the jackhammer is if you're using it during the day and the bulb is going to be three to five feet away from you then you can use the jackhammer.
Or if you're a person that says I just cannot put this in bed with me.
There's just no way I can't sleep with anything in bed with me and we've had a couple people like that.
Then they put the jackhammer on and they put the bulb underneath their band.
I don't think that's the best way to do it. I think it's best to sleep with your bulb right next to you without the jackhammer.
So yes, it does increase the amplification and by doing so it increases the static electricity.
And you're just getting static electricity shocks are not getting elected the shock.
So, but it's very discomforted and so that's how we would suggest to do that.
The Syrex array 10 this will tell inflammation inflammatory issues.
Can you explain is this a blood work test?
Who does this? Sorry, just saw that the cheek swab and wanted to work.
So the Syrex array 10 is a blood test.
So if you order it off our website, we will send you the kit and then you'll have to go get a draw.
So where do you go get a draw? Well, you can go get a draw at your local doctor at your at pretty much any clinic.
There's draw centers around everybody. So most people know that you can go get a draw somewhere.
But if you have a trouble with that, let us know.
What does the Syrex array 10 tell us about inflammation? So the Syrex array 10 is tested for antibodies to food.
It's tested 100 different foods. Many of them cooked raw different types of how you would eat that specific peptide protein.
Substance and in if you have, you know, let's say you're eating different foods that are that you have antibodies against every time you eat that food, whether you feel stomach upset or not.
Because most time you won't. It's causing inflammatory response. And when you get that inflammatory response.
You're going to have systemic inflammation. And you have systemic inflammation. It's going to be harder to heal from anything.
So go eat your food sensitivities is highly beneficial because you can help decrease systemic overall body inflammation.
And you could help heal from all sorts of things. So if you are eating, let's say we do a Syrex 10 and let's say, you know, cashews.
And so it reads them. I'll have some sample Syrex 10 readouts on the courses.
And so on the autoimmune course. If you go to the product disease autoimmune course, I have videos explaining the different Syrex antibody tests and videos explaining the Syrex array 10 as well.
But how it reads it out is greed is normal. Yellow is, you know, outside of normal and red is abnormal.
Beauty that you have a lot of antibodies against that thing. We're talking about foods. So let's pretend that that cashews were in the red zone for you.
And you just happen to eat cashews, you know, maybe even on a daily basis.
Every time you eat cashews, you're causing inflammatory reaction of the gut, which can cause all sorts of gut problems and and dysbiosis and all sorts of things.
And that's how you evaluate somebody, you know, for, you know, symptoms and gut disorders and stuff.
But from a cancer perspective, that's also going to cause inflammation systemically in the body. It's because inflammation of the brain as well.
So it's really hard to, you know, heal from cancer when you're dealing with systemic, when you're causing systemic inflammation of a daily basis by eating foods that you have antibodies against.
So, and then when you eat foods, if you're causing this inflammatory reaction, that inflammation is from these chemicals called cytokines and chemokines.
And then you're actually stealing your immune system away from killing cancer to have to deal with this with this reaction against this food antibody that you're exposing yourself to.
So the reason why a person may want to do a food sensitivity test, why do I have to look at food sensitivity, so I don't have gut problems. I have prostate cancer, I have breast cancer for good to say.
Well, okay, we are trying to heal the breast cancer, prostate cancer, lymphoma or whatever you're trying to heal. And you're causing all this inflammation every time you eat and you're stealing away energy from your immune system dealing with this inflammatory response.
It's going to be a lot harder to deal with cancer and it's going to make things get worse.
So that's why so sometimes when I do cheek swab testing, we had got inflammation comes up and that's I may suggest the Syrexia rate 10.
So, you mark here the one who asked the question about the bulb next. So true, I've never has the answers never had this issue with the bulb next.
Yeah, so I would go back to just the bulb next you take the amplifier off honestly. I would only use the amplifier during the day.
Well, to be honest, I don't use the amplifier at all. So it's to me, it didn't it only makes sense using it when you're having the bulb away from you. So that's what we've discussed lots of times on this about how to use the amplifier.
That's how why would I want to suggest to use it. I remember true, I always just try to sell, sell more products of things that.
It's between you and me that sometimes you don't be so thoughts on the terror test.
So, you're talking about, I think you're talking about the signature test. So the signature test is circulating tumor cells circulating tumor cells are going to be circulating DNA is going to be positive.
And the idea is that you're going to have elevated circulating DNA if you have if your cancer is more active.
But the truth is that's not a perfect test. But in all honesty, nothing is the perfect test. So we've had people do the signature test that affects somebody.
It was discussing it a few months ago that they had surgery on their colon cancer and the circulated tumor DNA went through the roof for a period of time after the colon cancer surgery and it just never came down.
Why is that? And I did know the answer to that. There's no research on that. Why that would happen.
And so I don't think it's a perfect test. I've never we have never recommended that for our patients. We've had a lot of patients that did that test.
But I don't it's not something that I'd recommend because I don't think it's there's a one to one correlation of having no circulated tumor cells and and having a lesser risk of the test.
Because the truth is is that whenever you whenever cancer started to develop in your body and even long before many times long before you were ever diagnosed with cancer, you are that cancer mass was already giving off circulated tumor cells.
So circulated tumor cells go and settle in different tissue and don't necessarily start growing and become cancerous and be then defined as metastasis for years.
In fact, we had a person ask the question earlier about, you know, they were doing really well and now they find out they have metastasis all over their spine. Well, they had circulated tumor cells there, probably from their original cancer.
And now it's just set up the environment. I don't know what has happened that the environment was right for it to just start growing and that is just the nature of the disease.
So does that person does a person who has active metastasis going to show an increase in circulated tumor cells possibly, but possibly not again, I don't know that that's the correlation that we should be looking at.
I think there's other tests that can give you hints of, you know, whether I'm still stable, whether I'm still doing well, I'm not against running that test too, but it's just a matter of how much money we have to throw at different tests and different lands.
I might be overwhelmed with the iron information I have been low and hydrochloric acid historically and take three to four with meals historically, I've been on the border of anemic, but never clinically low on my labs like recently.
So maybe you historically low on the border of anemic because you're historically hyper-coaffinity.
And maybe that's the correlation.
I don't feel tired. Should I take the optic there and more than once every other day, I would I would you're only doing it once every other day, I would increase it to every day.
I've taken it at just every other day, elevated your parents and levels, let's try taking it every other day, see if we get your full iron by the capacity back down into normal levels.
How do I figure out if this means cancer is using it because then I don't want to take for iron, well, you don't there, there's no perfect way to know if cancer is using it and the catch 22 is even if a person is anemic with cancer.
And so then oh, I don't want to I don't want to take iron because I could be feeding the cancer, well, you can't be anemic. So you're that's the catch 22. So you it's the game that you play, I would go, I would go to what a day of do the blood test again in two months and see what changes.
Can you have some confidence that you don't need a Syrex year if your inflammation labs are good.
So can you have some confidence that you don't need to do a Syrex antibody test if your inflammation labs are good. So what are your inflammation markers.
So your inflammation markers would be elevated fair to me like I talked about before or elevated see reactive protein would be elevated.
But the answer to that is no, so because your elevation in your systemic inflammation is going to be elevated every time you eat that food that you have sensitivity to.
It's very common that you can run labs on somebody that may have very bad gut issues and they have really bad.
Syrex 10 tests and they don't show see elevated see reactive protein repair to those are great indicators that's more for
inflammation at cardiac inflammation. But now I say it is everybody need to spend the money on a Syrex 10 I'm not saying that either I'm just saying that if
you want to do further investigation that's a good test to do for further investigation.
You talk about where are my sources of ill health I'm trying to do all these things right and maybe I'm not getting all the results that I want.
But you know, you might be eating all good foods but if you have antibodies to some good healthy food that you're eating you are causing inflammation you're causing ill health to your body.
So if you're doing well and you're you're feeling great and you're and you're confident that you know you're in remission and you're doing great.
It's a long time but if you're not and you feel like you're going in the wrong direction, then you need to look in some in different directions for answers.
So that would be a reason to run a test like that.
So I do know there's all these things cost money so you got to just weigh these things out.
The cancer is aggressive or not so you're talking about the signature test.
I wouldn't say that I wouldn't say that the level of circulating tumor cells equates to an aggressive cancer.
What is a test that you could do to find out the aggressiveness of a cancer.
There isn't a test know the aggressiveness of the cancer.
The only test that the only way you would rate the aggressiveness of the cancer is the growth over time.
So if I had a lump in my breast that was 1.3 centimeters round and two months later it was three centimeters round it doubled in size over two months.
It's an aggressive, it's an in an aggressive growth pattern.
And then you did something different, I don't know, maybe chemo, maybe the right, maybe nutrition.
And two months later it was still three centimeters round so there was no growth in three in two months of that cancer that it's in a stable growth pattern.
So is a cancer aggressive or not?
Any cancer can be aggressive at different times, any cancer can be stable at different times.
So how do you know that is by measuring over a course of time.
That's the only way you know that.
So we've talked fairly recently, I feel like a million bucks, but I can't seem to shrink my breast tumor.
Maybe Syrex will be useful.
Maybe, but if I apologize, I don't remember all the data in your case.
If you again, if your tumor is three centimeters and six months earlier, it was three centimeters, but I can't seem to shrink it.
If it's not growing, it's not acting like cancer.
So remember cancer is rapidly replicating cells.
So if my tumor is was three centimeters round, you know, six months ago, a year ago, it's not growing.
And everything I'm doing is keeping it at bay, then it's not acting aggressive.
If it is growing slowly, it is getting bigger.
Then, yeah, then maybe looking at other other sources of inflammation that are that are hindered,
hindered my ability to kill this.
Yes, that's that's exactly what I'm saying is that you could look at different labs in different ways.
I'm going to look at other sources of inflammation that I may be eating good times that I'm causing inflammation.
That's why I gave you guys all access to the chronic disease and autoimmune course to look at those videos.
I know many people are busy and I get it once the list of the needs out anymore than you have to.
But there's a lot of valuable information that you could say, hey, this might help me with my fight against this disease too,
just because it has a label of autoimmune disease.
Remember in my book that I wrote, you know, originally wrote back in 2010, I said cancer is an autoimmune disease.
That's really is my belief. It's tied to autoimmune factors.
And I think if you can figure that out, I think that's going to be a aid.
I don't get, I don't think everybody needs to do that, but I think that there could be a lot of benefits to that.
If you feel like there's just a missing piece of the puzzle there.
Any other questions.
And as far as the other person, where do you order that use order the side of extent,
if you do well to order that right on our right on our store.
All right, I guess we will call it a night. Thank you for being on.
Please ask that everybody be praying for the person that felt that they have metastasis on here pray for each other.
And know that we're praying for you guys to.
All right, bye-bye everybody.